What is Hutch doing though? [laughter]
>> I love Hutch. Everyone Everyone loves >> Hutch
is Hutch is my boy. [laughter] >> I love Hutch. And it's
Hutch doing the
>> Um, apparently Live and Learn is a little bit good once
you get to the Venezuelan boat attacks, right? Lonerbox took
a position on the Venezuelan boat attacks that I think was
I kind of understand how he got there,
but I do think a lot of people will hate that. And I think there's
a chance that I just side with Lonerbox on it over everybody
in my chat. And >> yeah, uh, >> there's a small chance
that I actually just side with Lonerbox here. Maybe, maybe. We'll
see. >> We I guess we were talking about your Venezuela.
No, we just were curious of your takes on the Venezuelan oil
tankers and the Maduro regime and all that. >> Oh, yeah.
The tankers. Well, it's not I don't think my take's that controversial
on the tankers. Maybe maybe Pisco disagreed. Um
it's when it comes to like any military action, there's like
there's the act itself and then there's also what broader goal
is it in aid of, right? Like I can go to any random country and
kill like 20 soldiers. I was like, "Okay,
You see this? Um, hold on. Give me a second. Paleoc Christ.
>> There's two big things that happened. >> I'm absolutely
fine with saying we walked and that's that. Now some libs owe
me an apology. The board was just destiny. They walked. >> One
is I objected to the format. Andrew wanted to do 12-minute openers
and I told Z 3 minutes or we walk. I'm not doing this. And then
Oh, so Z just like triple lied then. >> Z looks even worse
again
that she said it was her board. She lied. She refused to negotiate
at all. And then Destiny says, "No, no, no. I walked."
That's insane, by the way. That's like completely insane to me.
>> And then Andrew said, "I want the debate to be is like
um like Trump a fascist or something." And I countered with um
it's going to be more general than that. Like is he the most
authoritarian president or something like that because I'm not
going to play we're not going to do an hour and a half definition
debate game. This is >> that's reasonable. >> Um
and then after that apparently Andrew was like, "Oh, I thought
you guys were in Amfest not outside of it." No, I don't want
to do it unless you guys can get me tickets and we can't even
get tickets to it. And then I don't know what happened with Myra.
I think he eventually dropped off for a combination of random
things, but it was basically that. Yeah. But um like I'm okay
with saying that we walked, I guess. Like I it feels like when
Z was negotiating this, she she was giving them way too much
power. And I'm like between like me and Adam are like why are
we acting like we need these people at this event?
Dude, that is [clears throat] This guy's brain doesn't work.
There's no way he thinks this, right?
There's no
way
that he thinks
that he didn't need this desperately. Dude, that's nuts. Oh man,
that's He needed that so badly.
He needed it so badly to be on tape allied with Alan Adam Oler
in a way that could like become viral and get spread around.
He needed that so badly
and he just dude that's actually I'm like kind of I'm kind of
baffled at that. That's crazy
that he decided not to have a debate
because he didn't want to do 10-minute intros or something. And
I think it they went down to by the way in the text messages
I believe Andrew's side goes down to five minute intros right
>> like we absolutely don't like we can walk from this
very easily and yeah so I mean like there might have been a way
we could have negotiated keep them in but it would have been
dog [__] I didn't I had no desire to acquies to all
the random demands and [__] they're making >> I
feel like those guys need >> is he bro that that's there's
no way he's that stupid right cuz he has explicitly said multiple
times I need to collab or debate anybody I can and just get appearances
on the record so that people so it can normalize like hanging
out with me again. He said that
This debate does that massively, right? Yeah. He's got to be
There's something weird going on here. >> Needed you way
more. >> Exactly. Yeah. Like me. Yeah. I got [__]
I got the Mler here. >> I got Yeah. I think he like maybe
maybe that's what he really means is he's just transparently
arguing that Adam Mockler's here and I'm like gatekeeping Adam
Mockler. I that might be what it is here because
maybe Myron needs him. Maybe Myron needs it more or cuz Andrew
Wilson doesn't need any of this, right? Andrew Wilson's like
massive. He's still making massive amounts of money, but then
he's gatekeeping Andrew Adam Mockler, I guess. Bro, that's that's
insane. Insane self-sabotage.
Yeah, I
See if there's more to this clip. Also, Andrew has been weird.
He's canceled like three debates, I think, on me for like random
weird reasons. Um, don't quote me on that. I'm not trying to
slander him or lie about anything, but like I think there's been
like two or three random debates have just gotten
cancelled for just random reasons that he's not interested or
can't make it or whatever else. So, what about you two? >> Well,
it sounds like you walked from >> um I reapplied on the
16th, so we're waiting for the decision, I guess. Yeah. Um, do
what?
>> Got to take care of his wife's kid. Jesus. Stop. Chill.
>> It's a bit of a joke. Bit of a joke. >> What is
that guy? Does that guy just have a stream or like what's his
deal?
>> uh if Mutton's gonna take shots like that, I'm gonna
stop talking about him because I'm not going to be blamed for
whatever comes about from that. That's You want to start going
after Andrew's kids? I'm not going to be I'm not even going to
be in the sphere of talking about Mutton because I don't want
to get blamed for any of this. Okay. >> Hating women. >> He
does a podcast. >> There's like a secret thing to making
money on the internet, I think. Um which is having some kind
of course or class. So, it wouldn't surprise me if maybe his
like debate thing was making a ton of money or something. Um,
and maybe so now he's not as interested in doing other content
is my guess. Maybe maybe Brian's paying him on the whatever podcast
to be a regular. I don't know if that's true or not. Maybe. I'm
not sure. But >> he sells debate courses. Oh, >> so
this is like um this is like insane cope. Like totally
like
market illiteracy cope, which is pretty crazy. Um, one second.
You probably know this if you watch my stream because we aren't
really here but like if you do look at for the United
for the United States. Let's do yearly. Okay. So we go yearly
YouTube super chats yearly donations 2024
Andrew Wilson's Crucible $44,000
Canadian number six most super chatted channel in all of the
United States. Year before that 2023 were they up here at all?
No. Fresh and Fit was I don't think the Crucible makes it until
the next year. And then if you basically go like I think monthtomonth
before this
like there's Crucible number five for the month of November.
There's a Crucible number seven for the month of October. September
they are number four. More super chats than Candace. More super
chats than Candace in the month of
Charlie Kirk's death. August 2025 they are number eight. So,
they're clearly going to be like one of the top three or four
channels for 2025, I think.
Number two in July.
So, when when Destiny is like, "Uh, well, Andrew must make like
crazy money just because of his debate course." No, he's monetized
on YouTube.
Dude, this guy this guy's in so much trouble. This guy's like
in so much trouble. He needs someone else. He definitely Guys,
yeah, let him walk. He needs me way more than I need him. Are
you out of your mind?
I I don't believe that Destiny's that stupid. It's just again
like lying tone indicators to his audience so they feel
Got to be. There's just no other explanation for that level of
stupidity. May
are they? Oh, they almost fell for Oh, Jesus. Doro is number
nine in this month in May. That's crazy.
But in they almost fell into the top 10 in May. What about April?
Number three. What about March? Number six. February. Number
two in February. And in January they were number three. So, they
are in the top 10 every single month of 2025. In several months,
they are in the top five.
Have a good night, Ruben. Ruben, thanks for being here, buddy.
We'll see you later. Yeah. So, I just I think it's
you have to be like mathematically illiterate to think Andrew
Wilson needs other people for money.
Yeah. Anyway, did we finish that clip? >> Yeah. How much
does he sell for? Like 300 bucks each? >> I think the top
tier is like 500 bucks or something, right? >> God damn.
I don't even think he's that good of a debater. He just in the
end when he starts losing he just gets super aggressive and starts
like insulting >> Well, I mean he's good at that.
>> Destiny's become like Tim P where he says like
and the sick offense around him just like agree.
It's like Tim P. He's like Tim Pool, dude. It's
It's just Tim Pool. I I can't >> They're legal military
targets, but it's like okay, but why are you 20 soldiers? I don't
know. Just felt like it. Well, so obviously like when it comes
to
>> sorry, back to Venezuelan tankers.
>> Uh, in terms of the tankers,
they've already kind of gone against this principle because the
second I think there's been two more Caesars since the >> Yeah.
Well, somebody just said something and then everybody just piled
on to explain why the thing that was said was correct. It's very
sad. It's very I just And I I just like like H. You thought this
guy was compelling at some point?
>> First one, right? Yep. Or at least one. >> Apparently
the third were following. Is that right, guy? We're just following.
>> Yeah, they're following a ship. Yeah, >> my chat
told me they gave up, but yeah, they were just following one
of them. >> Well, we were following it. >> Yeah.
I mean, we're follow
I have nothing against
Europe European countries or the United States going after the
Russian shadow fleet. Um, you can say it's against maritime law
or that maritime law is kind of vague on what you can do there,
but I I actually don't care. I think that Russia is exploiting
that law. Do do you think international law is a meme and kind
of like who cares a [__] >> Um,
no. I'll support like 95 plus% of measures that are of principles
in international law. Um, the problem is is that like what do
you
>> what do you mean 95 plus% >> you do when you've
got you've got Russia aggressing on a country that everyone basically
disagrees with that action is completely unjustified. And then
um you can't do international sanctions on Russia because they're
in the Security Council. So you've got nothing else other than
individual nations uh that can do their own sanctions, but then
they can only enforce them definitively within their own wars
and even then that has legal problems as has happened in Europe.
So when I'm seeing this like Russian shadow oil fleet that is
basically like there to fund the Russian war machine to invade
Ukraine. Uh like someone catches that ship and impounds it and
yeah I don't I just don't I don't care. I think it's ask to clarify
please piece go is >> can someone explain to me is there
like a video that just explains
what this concept is because it feels to me like Iran probably
has a lot of its own oil.
Why is Venezuela being included? Right? Russia has a lot of oil.
Venezuela has a lot of oil.
Why is or sorry and um and Iran has a lot of oil. Why are they
sending oil to the Middle East? How is that helping them? Like
what are they doing for for um trading stuff around? Read an
article about the Russian shadow fleet. I understand the Russian
shadow fleet. I thought the purpose of the the Russian shadow
fleet was to sell their oil to other countries, but like Russia
sells their oil. So, is it that Russia can purchase that oil,
that Venezuela will do business with them, let them purchase
their oil, and then Russia sells it at like a markup or
like is it just a is it a shell game on trade restrictions in
some in some way? Well, I understand that I understand the difference
between like light oil and uh like heavy oil. I I I know those
distinctions exist, but is Venezuela a different kind of oil
that they need to do stuff with? Like is it it feels like maybe
you could argue it's like a shell game, but apparently Hank Green
did a good video on it. Maybe would it be >> So if you
ask me to give you the name of an organization that has pushed
climate change denial and confusion and delay so that they can
make billions and bill
>> or did he do a video on the shadow fleet explicitly?
Is it just where is oil coming from or is it the shadow fleet
stuff
billions of dollars? I would start out with Exxon Mobile. I might
also give you like Kico, Chevron, but there is a kind of oil
company that's bigger than all of those. In fact, if you add
up every oil company in the world,
>> okay, so evil Johnny Bravo, I understand Russia wants
to sell their oil to anybody who will buy it. What I don't understand
is
why Russia would be using their fleet of oil tankers to pick
up oil in Venezuela, unless that's to like mix their own oil
in with that oil from Venezuela to sell to other places in the
world or I I literally don't know the game that's being played
there. I know they don't need the resource of oil to buy the
oil to have the oil.
So I'm like, why are they sending a oil tanker from Venezuela
to Iran or something that is a Russian shadow fleet? It's like
to me it's like, okay, are you just putting all of America's
adversaries on this to manufacture consent for whatever you're
going to do to these ships that will be responsible for less
than half of the world's oil production. I think that this is
important because if the we only think of oil and gas through
the lens of how it currently works in like actually the minority
of cases, which is how I do it, we risk missing some important
stuff. Oil companies are enormous. They have tremendous economic
and political influence. But that is a very visible tip of an
iceberg. And behind them there is a deeper structure, a structure
that might be even harder to control and push back again than
behemoths like Exxon Mobile. But also maybe not. Maybe there's
also reason for optimism. So, first let's talk about these super
majors. These are the big big oil producers. There's a bunch
of smaller oil companies you never heard of, but there's a bunch
of big ones. They're >> I don't know. BP did oil as well.
>> Very powerful. They're very big. Exon Mobile is the
poster child. It's the only energy company that consistently
sits at the top of US companies. A fossil fuel firm that is punching
into that territory. Its market cap is in the hundreds of billions.
But there's others. You >> Sorry, not sorry. BP. Yeah,
I think I mean, wait, is BP like the the people who did the big
oil spill? The I'm sorry guy. That's not BP, is it? That's That's
the I'm sorry guy. Dude, I just made some connection. Okay. >> Heard
of them. Shell BP Chevron. >> I didn't realize I didn't
realize it was the same thing. Oh, I never but I said BP and
I'm like, wait, that's the I'm sorry guy. We're sorry. That's
Oh,
I just never made the connection in my >> Globally operating
oil and gas firms that control everything from extraction to
transport to refining. They're behemoths. They have revenue.
>> No, BP doesn't have gas stations in Canada that I've
seen. and influence comparable to major countries. Now, because
these companies are publicly traded or at least partially public,
they are somewhat transparent. They have metrics. They have branding.
They have footprints that we can look at.
>> Oh, maybe I'm just misunderstanding.
Maybe I'm I'm probably confused on something else then. Never
mind. >> And they're culturally legible villains. And let
me be clear, I think that they are villains and I think that
we should treat them that way. And I think that some portion
of people will have like a more robust understanding of this.
I hope that you're one of them. Most people won't and we shouldn't
be like, "Oh, you got to understand that actually Exxon Mobile
isn't that." No, that's not what we should do. We should continue
to treat them as the village that they are. But I think it'd
be better if some portion of people had like the bigger picture
in their heads. And you're going to be one of those people. There's
going to be lots of different ways of doing it and all the different
ways are going to be good. These companies have engineered disaster
for profit. Because of the size of these companies, it was a
big surprise to me when I first learned a couple of years ago
that if you add all of them up, they aren't even most of the
story. there is a bigger force and it's not in my yard you know
so like it's not how things work where I live so it totally makes
sense that I wouldn't focus on this but in terms of the world
in terms of extraction production burning creation of all this
oil and wait he's not just going to say OPEC is he like OPEC
was this shadowy thing we all don't know about that he can't
possibly be just leaving OPEC out right there's no possible way
that this is just a video about OPEC and then >> yes stateowned
oil companies control the vast majority of all oil reserves.
I've seen estimates. Oh, apparently this is a better video on
this.
>> Trump announced via Truth Social that the US would be
imposing an oil embargo on Venezuela, deploying its navy off
the Venezuelan coast to prevent sanctioned oil tankers from exporting
Venezuelan crude. Trump was >> Nobody knows about OPEC.
Wait, what do you mean nobody knows about? I Hold on. I should
just watch to the end. >> Only 12% of global oil and gas
reserves are held by the super majors. finding out that only
a fraction of the oil in the world is produced by the companies
I always think about as the only people involved in this. It
feels the same as finding out that like matter is only a fraction
of the matter of the universe. There's like a dark matter of
oil. And where I live, the super majors are the important people
to pay attention to. But globally, most oil production and most
oil reserves are under sovereign control. It's oil drilled and
traded by national governments or state oil companies. And in
many ways, these are
>> okay. All right. Stop watching TLDDR news uh years ago.
They make a lot of mistakes. Wait, was the Was there another
video? I think the same guy was posting Harmony was posting like
another video just two seconds ago. This was a short video.
Don't see the link anymore though. I've lost it. I've lost it.
I've lost it. You link the same thing both times
>> on Tuesday. You >> Yeah, you link the same thing
both times. Are you just looking for a quick rundown on the fleets?
Yeah, shadow fleet. Ukrainian sea baby drones hit another Russian
shadow fleet tanker. Are the Ukrainians just shanking? Just shanking
is fine, but sinking oil tankers in the middle of the ocean.
That seems not good to just go and bomb oil tankers and sink
them in the middle of the ocean in the Black Sea. That's crazy.
That's kind of not cool. TLDDR is very accurate. Whoever said
that is coping.
I mean, maybe >> cheered on by Hawks in Washington who
argued that embargo would heat yet more pressure on the duo given
his regime's near total reliance on oil revenues. Although we
should note it will probably exacerbate Venezuela's appalling
economic crisis and the regional migration crisis emanating from
the country. Within that true social post, however, Trump also
seemed to claim that Venezuela has in some sense stolen America's
oil and land. Unsurprisingly, this sparked some speculation that
the real motive or at least one of the motives behind Trump's
pressure campaign against Venezuela might be getting America's
hands on Venezuela's enormous and relatively untapped oil supplies.
This isn't actually is is it uh it's Venezuela and then
what country is it? Is it It's not It's not French Guinea. Uh
French French Guana, right? Has the huge oil reserve they discovered
off the coast and then was it Venezuela that was trying to like
shoulder in there to to get access to that? I'm not totally sure.
I think that's is French Guana, right?
I think I've I've looked at that like a little bit before Maduro
tried. Is Trump Is Trump about to try? Is Trump about to say
they stole our land and that he's just going to go take that
patch of ocean? The first time Trump has made this sort of suggestion
in Prince 23 at a rally in South Carolina. Trump said that, quote,
"When I left, Venezuela was ready to collapse. We would have
taken over. We would have kept all that oil." And in 2020, Don
Bolton, Trump's national security adviser between 2018 and 2019,
playing Trump, told him that Venezuela was quote really part
of the United States. So, in this video, we're going to explain
why at least some
I'm going to that pronunciation up every single time I say it
for the rest of time. Evil Johnny Bravo. Thank you. or think
Trump's campaign in Venezuela is really about oil and how this
all speaks to a long-standing contradiction in what we might
call Trump's oil policy. A bit of context. In short, Venezuela
has a lot of oil. In fact, according to data from the US Energy
Information Administration or EIA, Venezuela has quite literally
the world's largest oil reserves with something like three heard
of this country before. Let's go. Let's go.
Unfortunately, I think a huge chunk of our oil is tied up in
like borderline unrillable un unlike refinable. It's like the
worst kind of oil. It costs so much energy to to actually harvest.
Anything from like the oil sands. I don't know how much of Canada's
oil is outside of the oil sands, but I think the the tar sands.
Yeah, the oil sands. It's like where it all is. And it's like
insanely expensive to extract that >> 300 billion. >> Like
it's it's pretty unlikely to me that it oil prices would have
to get insane for it to become re relevant again. oil prices.
I think you remember like 20 years ago, 15, 20 years ago, oil
prices were kind of insane and they were extracting from up there
and it was a huge booming business and then OPEC opened the floodgates
and crashed the price of oil barrels and
that part of our economy just disappeared overnight. They were
just like, "Oh, it actually cost us like 10 times more to harvest
this stuff now than to just buy oil from somewhere else. So,
good luck." They abandoned like all of the refineries they built.
Everything they built to extract this stuff. They just ghosted
all of it. It's >> They've proven >> like I I want
to say like hundreds of millions of dollars in investment that
they just all walked away from. All the oil companies who are
building stuff in
reserves about40 billion more than second place Saudi Arabia
and more than triple that of Russia. However, Venezuela isn't
anywhere near as big a player in global oil markets as you might
thus expect. According to the EIA, for instance, Venezuela is
currently producing something like a million barrels of oil a
day. Roughly a tenth of the three big oil producers, the US,
Saudi Arabia, and Russia. China doesn't have oil. No, China does
not. China might produce some oil, but their reserves are not
big, right? That was reserves was the previous graph, right?
China's probably exploiting every bit of oil they can. You are
all producing more than 10 million barrels a day. This makes
Venezuela only the 18th biggest oil producer in the world in
between 17th place Libya and 19th place Angola who both have
only a fraction of the reserves that Venezuela does. Similarly,
according to CEC data, Venezuela only export about 650,000 barrels
a day compared to about 6 million barrels a day for Saudi Arabia
and about 4.5 million barrels a day for Russia. You get the idea.
Despite its massive reserves, Venezuela isn't actually a big
play in oil markets at the moment. So, what explains this apparent
underperformance? Well, we see at least three reasons. First,
Venezuelan oil is generally pretty heavy. For context, when oil
is pumped out the ground, it's an unhelpful mix of different
hydrocarbons that can't really be.
>> See, I told you I knew about heavy and light used to
anything. Hence why it's >> it was the DG who explained
that to me
You guys know, sorry. I probably need to narrow that down. It
was a metaloid sword who explained that to me before. >> Crude
oil, which does needs to be separated into usable petroleum products
like gasoline and diesel. However, not all crude oil is created
equal. Crude oils have different viscosities or gravities. Heavy
crude oil is more viscous, while light crude oil is thinner.
Importantly, heavy crude is more difficult to separate and process
into usable petroleum products, especially high-v value products
like gasoline and jet fuel. Unfortunately for the Duro and Co.,
Venezuelan crude is some of the heaviest in the world, making
it more difficult and expensive to refine. Second, Venezuela's
oil industry has suffered from chronic mismanagement. Venezuelan
politicians and officials have long treated Venezuela's stateowned
oil company, PDVSA, as a sort of corrupt piggy bank, extracting
money from the company that should really either have been spent
on improving Venezuela's public services or reinvested back into
Venezuela's decrepit oil infrastructure. Third, sanctions haven't
helped since really 2019. PDVSA has been under a strict US-led
sanction regime that has made it difficult for the company to
tap international capital markets or export oil. Sanctions have
obviously had a direct impact on Venezuelan exports. But they've
also reduced PDVSA's oil production because the company can't
really attract international capital to fund the necessary investments
in Venezuela's oil industry. Trump might be thinking that if
the US essentially took over Venezuela's oil industry, whether
by replacing Madura with a more pliant government or as Trump
implied on Truth Social, literally claiming Venezuela's oil for
the US, all these problems could be easily solved. The US could
remove sanctions and provide capital for the muchneeded investments
in Venezuela's oil infrastructure. The US could also help with
refining Venezuela's inconveniently heavy crude. Many of America's
oil refineries, especially those on the Gul Coast, are actually
designed to process heavy crude from countries like Mexico and
Venezuela. This is why the so-called shale boom in the US hasn't
made the US energy independent. This is another reason the tar
sand stuff sucks for Canada because all of the refining of the
heavier crude happens here and then all of the Canadian stuff
is like up here and you either have to make like massive pipelines
to send it all down or you need to build refineries like up here
and I don't believe they were really all that keen on building
a ton of refineries up here. >> Mexico and Venezuela. This
is why the so-called shale boom in the US hasn't made the US
energy independent as both Obama and Trump claimed it would.
Most of the oil produced in the US is produced via fracking and
is generally pretty light. Frustratingly for America, its refineries
were set up to process heavier crude from Western Hemisphere
producers like Canada, Mexico, and Venezuela, which means that
a lot of American oil is actually exported to be refined elsewhere.
And the US still imports heavier crude from abroad to be refined
and then consumed in the US. Revitalizing Venezuela's oil industry
would thus be good business for not just US super majors like
Chevron, which have outstanding operations in Venezuela, but
also American refiners. It would also probably bring down gas
prices because more Venezuelan production means more oil supply
and thus all else being equal lower oil prices. This would be
great news for Trump domestically given that lower prices at
the pump would help tamp down inflation which has become a real
political vulnerability for him lately. However, we should say
that lower prices probably wouldn't be good for American producers.
Global oil prices are already pretty low by historical standards
until Trump announced his oil embargo. Brent crude futures were
actually trading below $60 a barrel, the lowest they've been
since the pandemic. Unfortunately, US producers need relatively
high prices to turn a profit. Estimates vary, but most analysts
generally think prices have been at about $60 a barrel for American
shale producers to just break even. And there have already been
a slew of reports suggesting US producers are tightening their
belts with the Energy Information Administration now predicting
a drop in American output next year. This speaks to long-standing.
Is there oil in Israel? No. Shockingly
kind of fighting against the chosen people narrative. I think
Israel is essentially the only place in the Middle East that
doesn't have oil, like significant oil reserves.
I actually don't know why that is. I'm I'm pretty confident that
there's like almost nothing there. >> Intention in Trump's
oil policy. Higher prices aren't good for America's domestic
oil industry, which Trump's a big fan of, but unpopular with
his voters who really don't like inflation. Now, as a viewer
of TLDDR News, we know that you're a details person. So, you
probably check at least a half dozen reviews by forming an opinion
or making a Israel is tiny, dude. Yeah, the UAE is huge, dude.
The UAA the UAE is massive. Forgot about that. >> Compete
ticket purchase. You'd read the nutritional information on cereal
boxes. You even read the terms and conditions for some app you
almost downloaded. So when you're giving to charity, why should
this be any different? Well, today's sponsor, Give Well, provides
you with those details as an independent resource for rigorous,
transparent research about great giving opportunities. For example,
the recent analysis of the effects of cash transfers in poor
regions of Africa contains over 300 footnotes, which might satisfy
even the most meticulous readers. That's because give Well, >> UAE
is still like what two times the size in terms of area. No. Yeah,
about two times the size. I should have said Qar. Qatar would
have been smarter for me to go. 18 years researching global health
and poverty. >> Kuwait is a good is a better example and
only directs funding to the highest impact opportunities they've
found. These are things like preventive medication for malaria.
It costs about $7 to provide a child with malaria treatment through
the high malaria season. These treatments can reduce the number
of malaria infections and with enough treatments also save a
life in
Uhoh, this guy's gone onto his advertisements. My bad. I sorry,
I was looking up the size of countries. That's my bad. I was
doing that on another window. Okay, there's
that. actually doesn't explain anything about the Shadow Fleet,
by the way. I watched that whole thing and then that didn't explain
anything about the Russian Shadow Fleet, like the stuff I actually
wanted to know. Oh, well, I vaguely understood that Trump wants
to take over their oil like region, their regional oil reserves,
but I think Litterbox usually just argues that, hey, by seizing
these oil tankers, they're [__] with Russia, Iran,
and Venezuela at the same time. implication that the Trump regime
is being vehemently anti-Russia, pro-sanction, whatever they
can with this or
I would not believe that that is their their intent, even if
that might be a side effect of what >> Oh, yeah. That's
that's the that's the the caveat, right? Like the policy goal
is it's nothing to do with Russia, right? The policy position
is to [__] with Venezuela, which I don't support
at all. So, yeah. >> Right. So, so I'm someone who cares
Go
>> Well, no, you had a thought. Please go I was just going
to say like I care a lot about actual motivations and I [__]
hate pretext. And so maybe I would hear you that like you know
international law just a and I [__] hate pretext.
And so maybe I would hear you that like you know international
law just a meme. >> He just he just throws elbows like
that for no reason. What an >> and maybe I'll hear you
that you know it's not settled under US law the extent to which
these some of these treaties are self-executed. Maybe I'll hear
you that it's not >> sorry. The joke is actual motivations,
not just pretext. As in don't tell me what you say you're doing.
Tell me what you're tell me what you're actually >> Settle
whether US has jurisdiction and so we might as well try. Maybe
I could hear all that. If I actually believe the motivation that
was underlying this purported action, which is if we really cared
about the aggression from Russia, we should start first by doing
things that are very clearly legal and within our authority,
such as giving unrestricted amounts of aid uh to Ukraine and
and supporting them in their diplomatic efforts. And the Trump
administration has shown no uh desire to truly truly help Ukraine
the way it deserves to be helped. And on that basis, I I I view
and you do as well that these actions are just pretext.
>> You see Pisco making an impression of a Hutch face.
Wait, you're not taking the the thing from my stream, are you?
Maybe, maybe not. But I I had a face he made that I make fun
of that I laugh at. I don't have that off the top of my head,
but sure. >> To wararmonger with Venezuela, an action that
I'm against. I'm against that stuff. And I'm against also the
bombing of Iran. And so given that, uh, I'm not in support of
it as a policy matter. Even if I took the view that international
law or maritime law were just memes. >> Well, forgive me,
but I think what you guys are saying is this is the Trump administration
actually supporting the sanctions and and taking action because
my understanding is these tankers are like Venezuel Venezuelan
oil that's going to Cuba and also like Iran like are using them
as well. Like I don't understand the Russia connection beyond
just the Trump administration's >> Oh, hey, me and I or
I are on the uh the same boat here. I unironically
we're we're on the same boat. Okay. What the [__]
is the connection to Russia? It sounds like people are just saying
the names of countries I don't like to get my support >> up
for sanctions. Is that is that what you're saying? [snorts]
>> On Russian shadow fleet.
>> Well, because you're
the tankers we boarded aren't aren't Russian part of the Russian
shadow fleet, are they? >> The first one was it's owned
by a guy who Yeah, it's owned by a guy called Artimov, I think
his name is. Yeah, that's it was that's why it was sanctioned
under the Biden administration actually because it was part so
the tanker the connection is basically that Russia is uh sanctioned
by so many countries that it can't go into the territorial waters
of like European countries or uh the USA but what they can do
is they can have this fleet that is uh filled with ships that
are uh registered to one country but that country might not necessarily
agree that it's registered to them or they will have like um
uh devices on them can scramble people's data so that they can't
get tracked. And then they uh allow Russia to sell their oil.
Uh and also as part of because it's a fleet, they can also deal
with other countries that are allies of theirs like um like uh
China and also Iran because Iranian oil is also smuggled with
this Russian fleet. It's uh >> So I'm guessing that what
they're doing because they can't move their own oil is they're
leasing out their fleet to other people or giving them agreements
and taking part of the profits, right? That would probably be
one of the issues Venezuela has. And that would make some sense,
right? You fly your you you not fly, you sail your tanker over
to Venezuela. You can't actually sell your oil. So, you let Venezuela
load that up with their oil and sell it. And you just let them
like rent the tanker from you. >> It blended with the oil.
And that's why
>> when it goes to Venezuela as well, there's like going
to be some Iranian oil on there sometimes. And that's why that
first ship >> they said it was going to Cuba, but that
wasn't it final destination. Its load was too big to go to Cuba.
It was going to China probably or Iran, Russia. Um, I don't know
why someone in who this is real Kathy Doyle is in chat who's
asking >> You know who Kathy is. Come on, Loner Box. Be
real. Be serious. Loner Box, you know who real Kathy Doyle is.
Wait, no. Don't. Also, he's biting the bullet on this again.
[laughter] And I don't I don't say that as a pun.
Why does Why Why does Lon Box like take this so seriously? I
guess I I understand a little bit, but I didn't Somebody told
me like Lonerbox freaks out about this whenever you say it. And
now unfortunately, like since I saw it the first time,
now somebody's like he freaks out about it every time somebody
says it. And now I happen to see someone saying it. God damn
it. >> In Russia,
>> I pushed back on this by the way. I said no. Um, I don't
know why someone in who this is real Kathy Doyle is in uh chat
who's asking me why I support I have never in my entire life
supported the Venezuelan strikes on boats. That person's a liar.
They lie to me all the time. So >> Oh, never mind. He wasn't
freaking about that freaking out about that one. But speaking
of lying about him, >> Labox laughed at sniped Palestinian
children and justified it. He's not a good person.
>> Busted real
liar. A lying. [__] off. Anyway, >> all right.
Well, she's a >> Please don't be
Kathy is a lying piece of you, Kathy.
>> from my chat. Please don't be from my >> That's
a good That's a good segue cuz I wanted to ask you lean into
the slop a little bit. Why do what? Like
>> um you guys can say Kathy won. I You guys just like
go around and lie about people and they're like you're a liar.
You're like I won.
I'm like you that's not Kathy like actually has like some talent
as somebody who goes on and trolls people. This is like the lowest
level of trolling. I get that he wants to do it. It's whatever.
But
we love Kathy. Get rage baited. You're just covering yourself
in pig and then wondering why nobody wants to hang out with you.
It's just kind of kind of goofy. FDs hate you more than
like a thousand other liberals that I feel like are who have
who espouse views that are more contrary to their cause but for
some reason they really [__] hate you, bro? Like
can you explain that? Like how did when did that start? Cuz didn't
you start with Bread Tube? Weren't you like a pretty far-lefty
like Bread Tuber at one point? >> Listen socialist. You
remember a socialist
throwing Yeah. >> Are you a socialist still? Oh, are you
still a social >> I'm a social democrat though. >> What?
Okay. >> Can this peace go get some sort of like camera
microphone setup that doesn't have him 8 seconds delayed on his
audio from the video? Can that ever occur? Can we just have that
for fun? It would be really cool if I could see Pisco's voice
lined up with the video going on ever on Live and Learn. >> Yeah.
Oh, >> wait. This is literally his Why is his >> Are
you a socialist still? No. >> Are you still a socialist?
a social democrat though. >> What? Okay.
>> Why is his
>> listen listen Hutch? I came here to talk I came here
to talk to my lip friends about lip stuff. Okay. We can do drama
slop another time. Okay. I'm just saying
the answer
>> the answer the answer is really simple, right? Like
it's a narcissism of small differences people. Like the worst
thing for any
>> a bigotry of small differences. You're referencing the
Slatear CEX thing. He just called it the narcissism of small
differences. I think it's the bigotry, but or maybe I'm just
wrong. Maybe I'm just wrong. >> Political extremist group
or political radical is a is a traitor, right? Like that's So
yeah, obviously that's worse.
>> What loader box are you leftist anymore?
>> I mean, I'm like I'm a social >> Oh, wait. That's
a different concept. That's a small That's a different concept.
Interesting.
Um I thought he was referring to the slate the slate star codeex
thing. >> I'm a left social democrat. Like I support I
still support co-ops. I still support like I'm very like liberal
on immigration and Yeah. Yeah. Well, it's fine. Yeah. >> What?
Let's let's chart your your uh maturation or your I don't know
the development of reviews. What caused you to stop using the
label socialist? >> A few things. One is
the Europe, you guys know this, the European-American difference,
right? The um I think you guys had this argument when uh you
were talking about uh socialism in that panel. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And you were oddly >> Oh, it is. It is the narcissism.
Damn.
I I listen. I was willing to say right away that I was pretty
unsure of that. So, I backed off that. Right. >> Quiet.
You were oddly quiet, Loner, cuz there isn't that. >> I
reacted to the whole thing. What do you I wasn't on that panel.
I was watching it. Of course, I was quiet. I was on the panel.
Disinformation. Disinformation from >> No, no, no, no,
no. But what what I'm saying is there is this notion of a socialist
policy platform that um members of the Labor Party were advertising
as explicitly socialist. And so when Connor Boy was saying all
that stuff, it was true. And you had people like Counterpoint
saying, "No, no, no. Communism, socialism only means one thing
and it only means what we say. That's the only thing that's socialism."
And I would defend you if you were to call yourself a socialist
in the tradition of the UK. >> Um yeah, that's because
in Europe we define these words differently. Um like Clement
Alli is a really good example, right? He because he >> I
mean that's because in America they fought a war against what
they perceived as like the socialist menace, right? The communist
menace. Doesn't mean they they basically intentionally misdeed
>> the welfare state and all these very very obviously
liberal compatible policies, right? Because uh it the UK didn't
turn into a socialist country. Um I think the thing people miss
there is that um we've usually had like at least in the 20th
century we would have a socialist party like Labor the mostly
funded by unions uh as well as by like half and half unions and
other donors and then we would have communist parties. The communist
party in the UK hated Clement Ali and he hated them. He hunted
them down. Actually the closest we ever came to McCarthyism in
the UK was under Alli. Lots of civil servants lost their jobs.
uh most of them were innocent because they were accused of Soviet
sympathies or being communists. So that's the difference in and
that Europe we have >> that's the difference. We say things
correctly in Europe. Okay. Wait, do we do we think that Econo
Boy didn't know what he was saying with his words or
is actually not relevant. Um actually Americans just don't understand
that's a >> stupid socialist parties but they're not like
they're not socialist and they're socialist in the sense that
they are influenced by the ideas of Karl Marx and the reformism
of I forget the Bernstein I think it is. Uh yeah, they're social
democrats. Yeah, they believe in tax and spat like tax welfare
spending. >> It's like the same in Germany. They've got
the SPD, the social democratic party, and then they've got Dinka,
which is like the actual communist. And and that's just that
distinction doesn't exist here. Um people are a little too brained
for it. >> It does exist. It's just that like in America,
people who are social democrats call themselves socialists. And
but but people are but then or just American socialists are kind
of
>> Wait, didn't wasn't he just saying that the socialist
party there is like tax and spend usually unions? Isn't that
what social democrats are in the states?
>> So I
>> they're always both, right? They're revolutionaries,
but then they're also honey, I just want healthcare. So yeah.
>> Yeah. You can you can find you can find modern polls
recently where it's like you know it'll say that 40% of Americans
or whatever think that the country needs more socialism but what
99% of those people mean is like you know government provided
healthcare stronger more robust social but when people say that
they're socialists
and democratic socialists even
the argument was like oh the democratic socialism thing sock
dems these are like bad things these are people who want revolution
they they create like normalization for people who want revolution
And the people that were explicitly in that conversation being
referred to as revolutionary were not supporting
>> Well, mom Donnie identifies as a democratic socialist.
So would you say he's further left than you? >> Um probably
speaking incredibly generally. Oh well that would be weird cuz
Pisco just brought up a specific conversation where he was sort
of
on the definition of socialist
and that was what the conversation was about. So if he wasn't
referencing like anything around that, if he's talking about,
oh, Americans define it differently, but in a different context
or more generally, that would be really stupid because it actually
was brought up with a specific thing in mind for other reasons.
But yeah, I guess the what my understanding is that the difference
between a social democrat and a democratic socialist is that
social democrats want welfare and some things to be nationalized
and higher taxes. and democratic socialists kind of want the
same thing but more and also with a with a further goal of moving
beyond capitalism completely I think is the idea there's more
of a first principle there of uh decommodifying and ending
>> the first principle is democracy the first principle
is going as close towards the decommodification of labor right
that's what it is that's like that's that's what but the first
principle is democracy as in we will not do this in a way that
people don't agree >> the relation between labor and capital
so I'd imagine that's the That seems to me. Yeah, they're usually
farther. Yeah. >> And I don't know, you guys tell me, but
have the DSA always been this explicitly
Marxist or have they become more explicitly Marxist in in recent
years? Because I feel like the DSA that's around now, it's a
little bit different than the DSA that kind of emerged in 2016
in the wake of all the Bernie stuff. Um cuz when you look at,
you know, the the the more prominent kind of
>> did this guy not look into Bernie any of Bernie's history
at all? Do they do people get more explicitly Marxist than Bernie
Sanders? Like at an ideological level, the guy who like took
his honeymoons in commun took his like honeymoon in a communist
country. All of his vacations in communist countries, loves communism,
openly written about
how much he loves communism.
DSA, if you watch their conventions, I mean, they are like pretty
explicitly Marxist like across the board.
hold on. Is is Hut sure about that? Cuz
listen, I'm not an expert on Markx, but like Markx didn't talk
like he probably finds it weird because Markx didn't talk about
socialism at all. Right? So when they say they're socialists,
that's like burying the lead. It's not making it clear that they
believe in anything Mark said if they call themselves socialist
cuz Markx didn't write a single thing about socialism. You never
mentioned it. Right. That's that's Hutch's point. Yeah. I think
>> I can't say >> I'm so sorry to derail. Why is
someone saying that I'm not a mamanite but a marinite? Hence
my views on Islam. Isn't >> dude? Stop. Stop calling Loterbox
a marinite or a philangist. Stop.
Stop.
>> Just wait. What I like racist just because I'm a marinite.
What's what's going on here? What's this? Orientalist.
>> Wait. Who said it? Who said it? >> Someone Someone
said that I'm I'm a Marinite. Hence my views on Islam. We all
know who said we all know whose chat this is coming from. >> That's
racism. Wait, no. Wait, wait, wait, wait a second. Wait, tell
me the name. We We'll get the name. >> I missed the It's
gone. It's It's gone past. The chat's on fire. >> Who did
it? Everyone snitches will get benefits. You'll get a wrench
if you >> This is ape ape. >> Going to snark on people
and live and learn. Do it via Hutch's chat so that Hutch gets
the blame. Okay,
that's all that's all I'm saying. That's also like kind of a
joke, but >> you're under the hot seat right now. Wonderbox
is calling you out
>> What the [__] is a marinite? What is >> It's
a Lebanese Christian. They're like They're like Catholics. They
They love the French. Yeah, they're weird. >> But [clears throat]
that's me. >> Um if if we find if we got find the person
if it's in my chat who made a racist comment because of his or
I don't know a religious discriminatory comment, you guys you're
going to get banned. All right. So whoever said that >> what
are your views regarding Islam?
I I'm an atheist, so probably the same view that I have on Christianity
and
Um, let's talk a little bit about aesthetics, though. Good aesthetics.
>> Let's Let's talk a little bit about like the perception
of American politics where in your neck of the woods. Um, obviously
when Trump won there were concerns or fears that he had established
these kind of permanent
um demographic realignments and sort of remade this brand new
coalition that the Democrats would have a hard time contending
with in the future. that has just utterly collapsed in the last
year. Um, but is that recognized in England? Do you guys still
view as Trump as particularly strong politically? Yeah. What's
the perception over there? >> Well, first of all, I wouldn't
know about England because I'm Scottish. Uh, the the Trump >> I
didn't say England. I said your neck of the woods. >> You
said
owned. >> You said England. Rewind the VOD. Rewind the
VOD right now. Stop. No. Yeah. >> I don't know. Yeah. Trump
is I feel like Trump can only ever have so much influence on
the UK. And I I have a kind of like very subjective opinion on
why, but um
yeah, I I don't really It's really hard to tell. Probably not
like the failure like MAGA being in the problem that they're
in now is probably not
the Queen
Uh oh.
The Queenman Chatters who
raid when Boxer Destiny shows up on
I actually think most of those people just watch because they
genuinely like the show.
I I think most of those people just watch. That's like what they
do. They just want to watch. Hard to tell. Probably not. Like
the failure like MAGA being in the problem that they're in now
is probably not going to save us all that much because reform
are they've never been in power. They're always going to be the
fresh thing on the menu, right? Like so um
yeah, I don't know if it's going to affect them all that much.
Farage has been quite clever at avoiding the Trumpisms that would
get him into too much trouble >> in the UK. >> Support
for Brexit in the UK like was
>> it's like a reflection of of the right-wing rise in
America though. I >> Yes, I think that was Yeah. Yeah.
100%. >> Well, like I think to build on what Hutch is saying
is is like has the attitude about Trump changed? Like, is it
the end of the world or are people like, "Okay, that's not working
out for Trump. He's getting owned in special elections." Like,
what what's the vibes? >> I don't wait, where did they
how did they even end up, dude? What just
We didn't get like a solid conclusion on the Venezuelan oil tankers
and then we went to like socialists and then we went
whatever the we're on like the Trump coalition now. the DSA.
Was DSA this explicitly Marxist? Oh, also Trump thinks he Bro,
that was ADHD as Holy
>> I'm really It's hard to say because I don't really
I don't actually know how >> What do you think about Islam?
>> Uh, easily. I can uh follow UK opinions on on Trump.
Yeah. I don't know how often he comes up. >> American politics
a lot in your in your day-to-day or do you focus mostly on your
own? >> We we talk about it in dayto-day. Yeah. But like
on our political shows or or things like uh what do you call
it? Um
like like
>> you're keeping things very leisurely and bouncing from
topic to topic.
Okay. That wasn't bouncing from topic to topic. That was ping
ponging around in a
in a totally I don't know incomprehensible fashion >> on
BBC question time and things like that. The US politics generally
is it's only ever spoken about quite broadly. I think uh obviously
when Trump won that was a whole big thing in the UK because it
emboldened a lot of people that obviously are now >> Wait,
it's not my chat. This guy's not in my chat. >> Yeah, you
got your apology loaner. Don't worry. Just say no. >> Got
him. >> You gaslight
the IR
was trying to please. I was just like that's a strange thing
to see in a chat. Anyway, um yeah. >> So, basically you
guys are the Don Draper meme. You're like I don't really think
about you at all. Oh, I mean people do, but I I just don't know
how much >> See, this is the tough thing.
Something interesting just happened there. Okay, something interesting
just happened there. Pisco has got to evolve past this really
quickly or else this is going to get used against him. This is
going to get weaponized against him and it's going to be a problem.
Okay.
Um, if people say it's in your chat, if that happens, you just
go, "Well, if it's in my chat, they'll get banned, right?" Like,
don't give people the ability to like try to weaponize your chat
against you. It's stupid,
right?
No, but he's like, "Oh, it's not in my chat." But like, even
if he said it like he was relieved it wasn't in his chat. I'm
telling you, even if it wasn't his chat, it's not his fault.
Like, it's not. And and just the way he said it, I'm telling
you on Vibes, if he'd come out and said, "Oh, they were in my
chat." People will blame that on you. I'm I'm just trying to
explain it a little bit. Okay. People are gunning for you. People
are gunning for you. Okay. >> Like how much it shows in
our regular like political uh like broadcasting. I mean, it's
also just because I just I don't watch as much of like I used
to watch a lot of like question time and like breakfast politics
and stuff like that, but I've kind of strayed away from that
a lot more recently. Mostly just because
living in Scotland, so much of what happens in UK politics, you
have so little agency over it. Maybe that will change given how
much more uh diversity there's going to be in the next election.
But yeah, for now it's >> your personal thoughts. >> My
personal thought dementia dawn and he's falling apart and he's
not a
>> Is pretty fragile. So I'm sure he'll obsess over it
and find the guy. >> My personal thoughts is that it's
absolute chaos. Yeah, it's total chaos. Yeah. Like it's um it's
it's especially hard I think because
I don't know. I I think if Trump was maybe more of a concrete
like like ideological fascist, I mean he is a fascist but to
be clear, but if he was more like he followed like all the rules
of like what a fascist does rather than flip-flopping between
some of these uh like slightly more uh neocon hawkish positions
and then the other populist fascist I think because he's like
that. >> I'll be real. Um I did want to watch this or like
some of it could be good. Wait,
Epstein files, Amfest, and more. Oh, I would love to watch Pisco
react to that Kylo debate. I would love to see that. I feel like
I'd see him sweeping a lot for that Kylo debate. I saw so much
sweeping for that Kylo debate. I looked at I just looked at a
couple comments from places.
Oh my god. People were like, Kyla, you totally own that [__]
And I'm like, wait, did anyone watch that debate?
Like it was it was it was really bizarre to watch and read some
of the commentary. I'm like h it's fine though. It's fine.
We don't live on planet Earth. What was the topic about whether
America first is Christian or not?
Uh let's see here.
Somebody linked me this said this is Pisco trying to imitate
a Hutch face.
Let's see. Oh Hutch. You know, you guys will never want me to
review that debate because the more I think about it, I'm like,
"Holy crap, what a great guy I am. Thank you so much for the
bits, Eddie.
Appreciate you that." >> The more I think about it, the
more I'm
man, I was really too kind. >> Smile. It was his smile.
Hutch is it's that face and it's Hutch doing the I love Hutch.
[laughter] Everyone Everyone loves Hutch. >> Hutch is Hutch
is my boy. Hey, I love Hutch. And it's Hutch doing the
Is Hutch having a stroke? Is Hutch okay? Can we get Hutch on
some blood thinners right now? Is Hutch having Hutch is having
a stroke? Somebody save Hutch.
Good times. Good times. It's still not as good as his like psychic
terror face from that actual debate. That is a better picture.
I don't even know if I still have that somewhere. I think I think
it's just really difficult to do anything with that. It's like
very low resolution. I have to I'd have to go to the time stamp
and find it to renap it. Hold on. Can we find this? Can we find
this? Where is this stream at? Let me see if I can find it. Oh,
it actually is way closer than I thought.
Nothing will come close to this face he made
while speaking to Hutch directly. Nothing can ever come close
to this. Okay,
this is
a pain very few on planet Earth could possibly imagine. Hold
on. Motor box reviewing the Kako made me question if I lived
on Earth.
>> Ordered left. Meaning you have a responsibility to the
people closest to you. So just like it's immoral if you were
to feed your neighbors kids while your own kids go hungry. It's
equally immoral to support policies that harm your country's
people but benefit those from other countries. And this has been
explained in the catechism as well. So >> that's really
weird. So [laughter] you correct me if I'm wrong about the Bible.
My understanding is that God >> is this just like a random
time stamp or were we looking at a reaction? >> God gave
up godliness to come down to earth, right? He sacrificed it.
>> No, he did not. Jesus is also a god and >> Yeah.
But he also became man, right?
I mean, Jesus, do you want me to pull up the verse for you? God's
sacrificial, >> not the Trinity. Oh, no. It doesn't make
It's confusing, isn't it? Cuz like the they're they're all all
three are like the same, but also there's like the father, the
son, and the holy spirit, but they're all God. Oh, no. But then
the son becomes a man and the other two >> the son becomes
a man. >> Kind of do but also don't. Oh no. What? H what?
>> Love. We
I That's about what you would expect.
You want to show support? I would expect about that.
Yeah, that's about I I'm not going to watch this. I'm just gonna
I'm just going to end up getting in a fight, which I don't want
to do. Holy
moly. Oh boy. Um it's the start, but he endorses her debate tactics
right out of the gate. >> Ordered love, meaning you have
a resp.
>> Okay, great. So, God sacrificed by coming down. In fact,
he sacrificed so much that he died for not just his
>> Yeah, but like >> not just white Americans. >> The
Holy Spirit doesn't get No one gives a about the Holy Spirit,
do they? Like what does it do? It's just
>> everyone cares about the Holy Spirit. What are you talking
about?
That's
>> What? It's like a soul. Like, where is it, dude? Pretty
sure you get your soul removed and you wouldn't notice, would
you? Like losing your appendix. >> Wow. I have no comment
>> for I'm assuming the world, right? >> Yes. Okay.
So, sacrificial love seems to be a pretty fundamental piece of
Christian ethos. Would you not agree?
>> I have no comment. >> Yeah. Are you going to respond
to my claim that ordered love is virtuous? Like, do Okay. What
do you think? Like, if I were to feed my neighbor's kids, but
my own kids went hungry. Do you think that's virtuous? Cuz you're
loving your neighbor's kids. >> But depend on if you're
feel >> Yes. The Holy Spirit is supposed to be the Yes.
It's like literally when you get a good vibe that like pushes
you to do something and it works out well. That's like the Holy
Spirit. Oh, that's how I have been told. >> Feeling that
you're called to do so, right? I would imagine that God would
probably say that you would split it, right? Like I don't know
in what world be like, I have one loaf of bread. I can't possibly
figure out fractions and just like give all of it away. >> Poor
people exist. So yeah, that is definitely a >> I don't
know how that's a rebuttal. >> Oh, please please call it
out. Please call it out. >> Poor people do exist. Thank
you. Rich people exist. >> There's com was it was her and
Drew >> Oh, whoops. I paused. No, I didn't. You just stopped
talking and moving. >> She was uh she was being way too
nice. I thought she was being really like I mean she got concessions
out of him, which is maybe what you get for being from being
nice. But damn, this is I think this style is just better. Just
just bulldoze, man. These people are not they're not there in
good faith. Like why why why give them anything? >> Saying
that's not a pos. >> Okay. I mean, if that's what Why have
the conversation? Why waste everybody's time? Okay, just I guess
we're
okay. I All right. I Dude, what do you even say? What do you
even say? Like, I'll say probably what you should be doing here
is matching energy, alarming uptick, and dismissing others as
bad faith recently. Like, I don't think I I think everybody gets
this and it's like a performance to pretend you don't. Like I
can be when somebody comes on stream sometimes I'll be like a
higher temperature than them. But as soon as they're like, "Hey,
can I talk?" Or like, "Hey, I feel like you're doing this." I'm
like, "Okay, so I'll slow down. My bad." Right? Cuz otherwise,
if I just thought you were like a loser who couldn't possibly
listen, why would I bring you on stream to talk? Why would Like,
it's pointless.
Just
Yeah.
Everyone nowadays is just farming viral clips for X in Tik Tok.
Why'd you spell it with C both times, dude? I I kind of wonder
if Destiny was not like an actual criminal.
I kind of wonder if I would have like fallen out of this space
cuz I was already like so done when Destiny was taking this road
and doing like this kind of performance where he never wanted
to engage. I was so done at that point with him. I wonder if
I would have just like slowly faded out of this space
cuz I I really don't like I have no use for this at all. And
Kyla has explicitly said this isn't the way she operates, that
she wants to be like good faith to conservatives. So, how can
she justify? Sneak is almost certainly as racist and has very
very similar beliefs to Sarah Stark, but she could be like so
kind to Sneo and then she's talking to Sarah Stock and she's
trying to like dunk on this person. It's not sincere. It's not
been sincere the whole time.
A very It's very interesting. There is quite literally a Bible
verse that says No, wait. If you're going to cite the Bible,
there is a Bible verse that quite literally says that if you
were to feed that if you were to take care of someone else's
child before your own, you are worse than an unbelievable
than site where that's from. >> It's in first Timothy something.
I don't >> Okay. I'm I'm sure that's there. >> Why
is it quite It is. You guys can look it up. That's a verse. >> Sure.
So, here's one of the issues, right? is you're creating like
this world where essentially I have a loaf of bread and >> bro
I'm sorry
I'm not I don't want to sort of fight I really don't where did
this guy compare this to DMS's okay compare this to Denim's reaction
to the content nuke >> okay I'm I'm sure that's there >> why
is it quite it is you guys can look it up that's a verse >> sure
so here's one of the issues right is you're creating like this
world where essentially I have a loaf of bread and I'm going
hm >> like what are the very easy ways to handle reaction
this debate is somebody makes a claim. I don't know if that claim
is true. I'm going to go look up that claim. This girl just said,
"Oh, here's like this passage." Everybody's like, "Sure." Yeah,
that exists. >> Why not just go resolve that ADHD runs
me 619? Thank you very much for the five gifted. Appreciate it,
dude. >> Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Like, just go check
that. That's like something you can do. >> Actually, I'm
going to give none of this. But the America first, like look
at America right now, right? America doesn't go, we're actually
going to spend zero money on America.
Can we look up the Well, we did look it up. It does exist. It
is 1 Timothy 4:6 or something. Wait, that's not it, right? Hold
on. 1 Timothy 5'8.
Anyone who does not provide for their relatives and especially
for their own household has denied the faith and is worse than
an unbeliever. This is basically under different interpretations,
you can basically say this is them saying you should take care
of your family before everything. Like the ordered love thing
is probably just a part of Christian doctrine. It's like you
shouldn't be self-sacrificing to the point that it harms your
family. You have a you have a duty to your family first and then
it works outwards, right?
That's not the same thing. IMO anyone does not provide for his
own and especially those of his household, he is denied the faith
and is worse than an
right? It's like there are different interpretations of it from
different things. If any but if any provideth not for his own
and especially his own household, he hath denied the faith. It's
literally saying there's like a hierarchy to how you to your
obligations, right?
And that is what Sarah is arguing is there's a hierarchy to your
obligations
and that the closer people are to you, the more obligation you
have to them. And that Americans are broadly not getting taken
care of is where it should go. But Sarah is like kind of and
not really capable of arguing. You think that's massively off
of what she said? I'll just roll it back and we can check. It's
a Bible verse that quite literally says that if you were to feed
that if you were to take care of someone else's child before
your own, you are worse than an unbelievable.
>> That's literally exactly what she's saying, right? That's
literally she is saying precisely what's in the reverse or what's
in the verse. I don't read it as don't turn your back on your
family. It doesn't mention outside of the family at all. Wait,
what is the converse? and he provideth not for his own and especially
his own household. People who don't take care of their relatives
and especially their own families have given up their faith.
They're worse. Okay. So, you're saying don't give but I guess
I guess I would say probably is a correlary of this if you're
if you're giving stuff away to other people, right? Yeah. Sarah's
position is pretending we have to give all we have and at the
expense of our well-being. Then she gets grilled on how she doesn't
want to actually help Americans at large or without it being
selective. No, I don't think so. So from what I remember, they
both did the same thing to each other because they were both
on operating on the same level of like intellect. Okay, you're
saying we have to give everything away and we have no principle,
no line. And then you're saying we can't give anything away and
you have like no principle or no line. And then they didn't have
any actual discussion.
That was both of them going back and forth with each other. That's
that's what I recall from the debate. >> But then site
where that's from. >> It's in first Timothy something.
I don't >> Okay. I'm I'm sure that's there. That is it.
Quite It is. You guys can look it up. That's a verse. >> Sure.
So, here's one of the issues, right? Is you're creating like
this world where essentially I have a loaf of bread and I'm going,
hm, actually, I'm going to give none of this. But the America
first, like look at America right now, right? America doesn't
go, we're actually going to spend zero money on Americans. We're
not going to have welfare. We actually do have these things.
And then we also do things like US aid, which I imagine you're
opposed >> Like they're both just strawmaning the other
person's position. And so the whole issue with being a >> I
think letter box is not >> is there is a fundamental piece
which is caretaking of others right if you want to look for example
I'm sure you know this do you know the parable of like the good
Samaritan >> yes I do >> okay so what is what happens
in the good
>> there's what why are you yes I understand like if someone
why would you ask me that question >> suffering [laughter]
you can help them out but there is a certain amount of resources
that America has if we were to give away all >> you understand
that like foreign aid is like less less than 1% of the federal
budget. No, it's like less than 1%. So, >> yeah, that's
what I said. Why don't you turn it into like a ratio thing and
ask where the line is? That's where the debate is. It's not both
sides of this going. You say we can't do anything over here.
You say you're saying we can't give any foreign aid. No, you're
saying we have to give all foreign aid. Okay. I >> like
we shouldn't have a limit on foreign aid. Um, foreign aid can
be a stupid place to take stuff from. foreign like USA ID might
be a stupid place to take stuff from but like that's where you
actually win the argument. >> America is starving their
own children. >> Not that USA ID I can justify all of it
over anything else. It's that hey you are supporting basically
people are doing this bait and switch where they say oh here's
all this money we're spending on USA ID and it's for like gay
kids in in Guana. Okay. And then you look at that and they avoid
the fact that they just cut like $50 billion out of taxes. Okay.
like a thousand times whatever that Ghana gay kid program was
and they just like cut that out of uh income for the government.
So they're basically adding that to the debt >> children
to build food kitchens in Sudan. That's not really how that works.
>> All of our resources to other countries and our own
people's >> because nobody is saying give away all of our
resources. >> A limited amount of resources. Yes, >> that
is true. >> Just like there is
level there also is when it comes to your nation. Do you >> is
he going to comment on how when Arerodite said poor sorry when
Sarah said poor people exist before Arerodite was like gh why
would you even say that's so stupid of course they do and then
erodite 30 seconds later fractions
trillion dollar budgets exist >> I think that what I'm
advocating for when I'm saying that America first so when I say
America first is on Christian is because fundamentally what it
does is it looks at every resource that America has the number
one economy in the world right trillions it's worth trillions
of dollars a year and it says you know But we can't help others.
It has to fundamentally be about us all the time. Not only Not
only is this stupid >> It's too bad that Sarah sucks so
badly at uh Arodite. Sorry. Sarah could have made Arerodite nuke
herself here if she cared at all. Right. It's just like, okay,
the way I see it right now is bunch of rich people decide that
we're giving away a bunch of tax dollars to other people and
then they brag about it to their other rich friends and then
we've still got lead in the water in Flint, Michigan,
right? That's that's like the kind of populist rhetoric you should
be doing to make people bite the bullet of like, yeah, well,
they they'll go, well, the money should come from somewhere else.
And it's like, well, it's not coming from somewhere else. So,
I'm going to take the things that people use to to show America
is like this really charitable nation. I guess if you're if you're
not going to give it up in taxes, we're just going to take it
from these people. Probably the rich should pay more in taxes,
but we can't really do this, right? >> Stupid foreign policy
because soft power is incredibly important and it weakens our
allyships. But on >> Oh, Flynn's been fine for years now.
Bad virtue signal then. But I'm saying you you want issues like
this that you can point to, right? issues in your country that
are going on where you say the charity thing has gone too far.
We need to be less charitable in general as Americans to people
who aren't Americans. I think that's broadly something they want
to do. The real solution is the government needs to spend money
less on like business and more on improving the lives of everyday
people and they have to fix the fact that your labor is being
consistently devalued. These should be the two priorities of
government. They have to do whatever they can to fix those two
problems. Anybody who's not addressing those two problems directly
is a problem themselves. Okay. And I think the foreign aid thing
is sort of how you get people's attention.
But unfortunately, the way the foreign aid thing is being used
right now is by who are trying to steal all of your money, who
are trying to bankrupt your country, who are trying to loot your
country as like a vault. They're they're looting your country
and then they're just going to off. Okay? That's the way foreign
aid is being used as a cudgel right now. It's like, oh, we'll
cut the foreign aid and then we can, I don't know, like cut more
in taxes or something just from people who are literally using
populism to loot your country of all of its wealth. So, that's
the problem is all the people who embrace populism currently,
that's the issue with populism is basically anybody who's going
to use populism is never going to use it in your favor. They're
going to use it for their own ends. They're going to be selfish.
They're going to steal all your money and then they're going
to [__] off. That's like the only way this ever works.
And it sucks because the other people who speak basically sound
like they don't care. >> On top of this, it's fundamentally
selfish. What you're saying is I know I have a lot, but nobody
else can have any of mine. That's not Christian. I'm not saying
America should bankrupt itself and give away all of its money
and then like live in the gutter. That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm
>> So this is ultimately going to come down to the issue
where libs lose every time. It's going to say, "Okay, I'm gonna
say no money to X, Y, and Z until we no longer have homeless
vets." Once the homeless vet problem is solved, we can look at
doing
like broad,
you know, global welfare again. But once we have until we don't
have homeless vets anymore, right? That's like I'm going to put
the I'm going to put a a group of people above whatever non-American
group you're talking about. Hey, no more homeless vets. We have
homeless vets. I don't care. I don't want $1 spent on any of
these other things until we don't have homeless vets. Yeah. Nobody
on the right is advocating for this type of [__]
They're about to.
They're about to cuz they're going to keep getting outflanked
by total for as long as they don't. >> I'm saying is that
America first supports the banishing of US aid. It supports not
helping Ukraine in the war. That to me is both fundamentally
selfish and uncchristian.
So what I think that America first is
>> and you can say America first is just like an ethos
and it's about putting the American people first. It's not about
not helping people. It's about making sure that your priority
with your policies is making sure America is prosperous. Americans
are happy and then when there is stuff when there is enough left
over because there isn't right now. We have this whole economy
right we have this trillion dollar economy. The issue is like
actually probably a better line here is just to actually flip
this and say wait do you think the rich pay enough in taxes because
we have this economy
but none of the wealth is trickling down. So there are a ton
of people in America who are like going hungry who are not taking
care of who are not happy even people who like want to work like
they're incapable of living prosperous lives right now. We need
to solve that and I don't think we should pay a dollar to anybody
else around the globe until we start solving that. I don't think
we should be doing that at all. I think that's probably the direction
you have to go in, right? Because it's like, well, there is a
trillion dollar economy, but it is not trickling out. It's not
the wealth is not getting to all of the country, right? And that's
what we need to fix. And one of the ways to fix that is to just
start cutting these other things. And I understand you don't
want us to cut those other things, but I'm not sending charity
to another country while there's a homeless guy on the street
who's a veteran who served this country. It's [__]
up.
>> It's simply, it doesn't mean we can't help other countries
or even other people live outside. >> You support the banning
of US aid. Can I finish please? >> Do you support the banning
of US aid? >> Can can I finish what I was saying? >> No,
you can't. No. Answer the question. US ID, which again is like
less than 1% of the federal budget, which saved hundreds of thousands
of lives
over a period of years would have been millions. Yeah. Yeah.
You should you should probably answer that question if you think
it's not worth 1% or less of the federal budget. How would you
argue that? That that that should be getting done, but that should
be rich philanthropists who are taking that on. That we should
offset that to rich philanthropists. So, Americans are being
taken care of with their tax dollars first and then some rich
guy wants to have his name on like a wing of an African hospital.
Let him go donate a bunch of malaria vaccines. There's a it's
a hugely rich country that he can get way more clout off of that
and then we can just have, you know, our vets not be homeless
is probably how I would argue it if I was trying to go in that
direction.
Yeah. 1% of the budget is also a ton of money. >> Can I
just ask you the same question? >> So we put American interests
first. That's what it means. It it means that we are not prior.
>> You do. Most of the federal budget goes to Americans.
All like almost all of it. >> Be selfish. I hear you. >> So
even with Ukraine, I mean even if I'm not even fully against
sending any money or helping out. And by the way, the other side
of this is it's to say, okay, well, I'm going to argue for us
to take the money from that and put it towards these programs
that are taking care of Americans, and you advocate that we should
send it to Africa for malaria vaccines, and we'll see who wins,
right?
Then we'll see who wins. Look at the numbers.
Um, you you don't understand the way people are thinking about
this. even less. I guarantee you if you could get if you could
tell people we'll take 10,000 homeless vets off the street, they
would be okay with US ID getting abolished if you gave them like
explicit trade-offs. We're not going to do vaccines in these
countries. Oh, well, somebody should take care of that. Why does
it have to be the American taxpayer?
Why is it incumbent on the American taxpayer to do that? See
you,
By the way, I'm not saying that Lonerbox is wrong that he's that
he's like describing something that America can't do. I'm not
saying that. I'm saying America and the government of America
are not fulfilling its obligations to the American people, right?
And there are a lot of people who think, okay, everything else
until this changes, which is broadly like an immature way to
view things, but that's how they view it. And I think people
just aren't engaging with like that way of looking at things
at all. They're not engaging with it at all. They're just going,
"Well, actually, technically, moneywise, like it doesn't cost
that much." It's like, I don't care. I don't care. You don't
get to brag about the US saving lives all around the world while
Americans starve, while Americans are like on the street homeless,
drug addicted. That uh Yeah. No, Ben. Uh portability, this is
where it should go, right? It should be about taxing rich people.
It should be about resetting like the economic standard. That's
what it has to be about.
But I'm telling you that in terms of why people want to do that,
they do not want to keep spend sending money to other countries.
They don't want to keep spending money on different things and
then getting told there's not enough in the piggy bank left for
them. So the American government, the American American politicians
can stop lying to people and saying that certain things cost
too much money while also sending out roughly that much money
to other countries, right? Like, hey, we can't afford to, you
know, build a couple we can't afford to build like an apartment
building in, let's say, Detroit or something for vets. Can't
do can't can't do that. Okay, but you can send money to Israel.
Roughly that much money. Wait, what do you you So you think roughly
that much money? I was talking about building one apartment building
in Detroit for homeless vets. Even less. Roughly that much money.
That's what I'm talking about. Now you go ahead and rebut and
tell me how that's not actually that's like, you know,
you think you think we could pay for that? I mean, this is an
aside, Marty Epste, but I I don't doubt that there's corruption
there. I do think like broadly your country should pay for research
and stuff like I think that also got cut. Not maybe not with
USA ID, but by Doge as well was a lot of like American research
stuff. And those things always have like a ton of loss, like
a of loss. But it is still good to try to prioritize and make
those things work. And I would rather shake those programs up
than just cut them. What else are we looking at here? Missing
the obvious. If you halted, the Israelide conservatives would
still fight the vet spending. No, I know that, Ogre Boy. I'm
telling you, but hold on. You have to you have to you do have
to put that on them, right? And I I agree with you. That is the
problem is everybody who actually engages in this rhetoric in
any serious way who has political poll as in like JD Vance, Donald
Trump, all of these people, they have no sincere commitment to
the people. They are just doing it to loot your country. And
so I wouldn't vote for them. Even though I think broadly on rhetoric
I could agree on some things, I wouldn't vote for them because
they are dishonest, disingenuous actors. They are total losers.
And I think if you don't compete in this rhetoric at all, if
you just keep telling people that actually no, the way things
are is actually what should the way it should be, you are going
to get blasted repeatedly.
If not by Trump, then you're going to get outflanked by your
own leftists in your party. Anyway, >> out Ukraine at all.
Because if we were to help Ukraine and that helps America, I'm
fine with that. But I'm only help Ukraine if it helps you. Very
Christian, by the way. Look, I'll be generous to you, but only
if fundamentally it's good for me, guys. You know, you got to
get that money >> on a foreign policy level. If we Why
would I support foreign policy? >> So, just knowing that
like a base level loner box does want to support audit, I do
understand the total lack of reaction, right? I do understand
not really wanting to comment very much on this debate. I think
that is the best way to show support toite is to just really
not talk that much. >> That is bad for America. Like what
kind of what are you to help Ukraine and that helps America?
I'm fine with that. But I want you only help Ukraine if it helps
you. Very Christian by the way. Look, I'll be generous to you,
but only if fundamentally it's good for me, guys. You know, you
got to get that money >> on a foreign policy level. If
we Why would I support foreign policy that is bad for America?
Like what kind of what are you trying to >> Why would supporting
Ukraine be bad for >> Foreign policy.
>> Wow. Wow. >> That is good for America. I'm fine
with >> How is US aid bad for America?
>> I think it would depend on the specific US aid like
>> Okay. How is giving malaria injections to the poorest
in Africa which has been banned by the way? >> We have
poor people here in America like would you rather money go to
people in another country or go in America? >> Do we have
welfare? >> Sorry. The American healthare system really
if you is it
what do you do if you want a malaria injection in America? Um,
how do people get malaria
injections in Are there people who are short on a malaria vaccine
in America? >> Wait, are we pretending that the USAD stuff?
Wait, is he trying to apply the Ukraine argument that it's like
we just had these we had all these vaccinations for malaria just
lying around and that the USA ID programs wouldn't drive production
of malaria vaccines?
I think that's where he's going, right? He's trying to do the
Ukraine argument, which is a good argument, which is like we
have surplus weapons and it probably cost us almost as much to
just like decommission them as it would to just send them to
Ukraine and let them blow things up. So, it's like the best of
all worlds. But I think he's kind of doing that for vaccines
here. >> Are there people struggling to get a malaria vaccine?
>> That's literally how you did the first
Wait, do you think so?
Wait, do you think I didn't more than double the length of that
debate? Simpo, I I addressed literally like every argument made.
What are you talking about? I think it took me till like the
very end to be like, "Okay, I'm kind of done. Checked out of
this." I I literally checked every single argument as they were
going along, gave my opinion on it. >> Hang on. >> Oh,
and then we went through it a second time. I forgot. No, I mean
calling out anything NY did. Well, I found her behavior like
super offensive, like coming in super hot, not giving the other
person a chance to talk, not taking seriously or or actually
like listening to anything they were saying and then straw manning
their position and then doing the straw mans that you were mad
that she had done backed to you and then right like and then
freaking out for her using tactics that you had used against
her. Yeah, it was it was just pretty rough, man. >> Medical
bill in America and nothing is happening. How hard is it? I want
to get the the AI that talks to you and just ask them these questions.
>> Yes. Do you support Wait, hold on. Do you support welfare?
>> I support like Yeah, in certain >> Food stamps
are for people getting food >> Yeah, sure. In certain situations.
I'm not fully >> What are the situations you would not
allow people to get food stamps? >> Um, if they're just
like if they don't have a disability, if they're not working
a significant hours, if they're not trying to find a job, I don't
see why we should pay for them. >> Is it just because it's
not a risk in America? Is it? Wait, how many people in the US
get malaria?
>> But so, uh, okay. So, a lot of people on disab on, uh,
food >> stamp. Most most There's like 2,000 cases of malaria
in the US, and it's mostly from people who catch it abroad. I
don't Okay.
>> Yeah. I think he thinks that like USA aid wouldn't drive
production of a malaria vaccine.
I feel like it would. I don't know. I assume most production
of malaria vaccinations or malaria even treatments I guess meds
and stuff would be
wouldn't that all be
like based on philanthropy
like the entirety of it
like almost no African country is just paying for that stuff
right it's all just philanthropy being sent over there >> Florida
Texas and Maryland had an outbreak in 2023 a very small one but
they went 20 years without it yeah this is not like this is not
these places are not infested with malaria like what what seven
deaths a here since 2007.
Okay.
>> Uh, by the way, I'd probably agree with most USA ID
programs.
Like, I'd probably say, yeah, there are way more cost-effective
places to cut from the budget if you were going to cut. And realistically,
you need to address the revenue loss that's happening. Not even
not even the cost. You need to address the substantial revenue
loss that is happening already and is going to continue happening
as you reach a population cliff. There's only one way to do that.
Most cases are people who came from Africa, returned from Africa
and they didn't get prevention.
>> I don't know. [__] me. >> That has
to be what he's arguing, right? Is he thinks it's like silly
because those vaccines have to go somewhere because they were
already made? I think,
right? Is that not the case?
you for supporting war vets? Are you for helping them in that
way? >> This is kind of going Okay, so you >> She's
not gonna answer the question. Just to clarify your position,
you are okay with us having foreign policy that does not directly
benefit >> it makes sense. It makes sense that America
wouldn't have a general it wouldn't have a general malaria vaccination
program because it was eliminated in 1951. Um [laughter] there
were like what two instances where there were locally transmitted
cases 2023 and 2003. Yeah. Of course you would have a general
policy against this that's like seven people a year and it's
mostly people who got it from abroad. Yeah. What the Okay.
Do I say the thing that's like obviously true but nobody wants
to deal with it? Someone just said malaria vaccines should all
be true or so should all be free. Not true but free.
Um is Africa built to handle that? Are you are you like spawning
in a ton of people with malaria vaccines that they're not built
or don't have the infrastructure to feed at all and just inviting
like mass starvations happening in those country mass starvation
events happening in those countries? Like not that like you should
help with that too,
but like if suddenly you increase like
if suddenly you increase
like the life expectancy of people massively, is that not a real
thing that will literally happen? I'm just I'm I'm literally
asking. It seems like obvious, right? It seems really obvious
to me that that would happen. Yeah, but we don't talk about that.
Okay. I hope that's a part of like the thinking for these programs
that it's not just like malaria vaccines and then no food aid
to go along with it over a long term. Well, that's I was gonna
make a great a great leap forward like um sparrow analogy but
but the sparrows here are like the actual malaria virus.
>> United States and malaria. [laughter]
>> Hate was also part of USA ID. But is that I'm saying
are they tied together? Not do they both exist. I'm saying are
they tied together? Are they doing projections of how the food
demand is going to increase in those countries? >> [__]
me. Stupid >> America. Is that your position?
So because you I was saying I have American foreign policy that
benefits America. That's my position. What's your position? Do
you support us how is US aid bad for America? How is it not benefiting?
Well, in large part when you help African countries with like
some of the most destitute issues that they have, those countries
tend to be warmer towards America. So that for example, >> that's
not really a Samaritan argument though. It's good because it's
good to do. It's it's good because by I'm guessing by Christian
ethics is a good Samaritan if they have something extra that
can go a long way for someone else. Like if less
this is true I think probably everybody in the world believes
that maybe that's their personal thing that they should handle,
right?
Like if you wanted to have create like a discretionary thing
where people could put extra taxes in,
right?
I do believe there there could be an argument for, hey, you don't
get discretionary funds to like spend my tax program to spend
my tax dollars on like charity in the third world. I don't think
that's appropriate
that like but if you want to run a governmentr run program that
is like collecting that funds and then going to spend it on those
things
I'm totally behind that like UNICEF or whatever in Canada right
is UNICEF's got to be global right you guys get UNICEF everywhere
I just remember when I was a kid you go get like the pennies
and the the nickels for UNICEF oh UNICEF's the UN okay yeah so
like why wouldn't it be that stuff I I think probably
collecting
collecting my money at the point of a sword and then sending
it somewhere else does feel a little weird to people. Is that
is it something that has to be cut entirely? Probably not. But
I do think there's like I do think if you ask people about it,
especially when stuff's going bad economically.
It's difficult. The whole good Samaritan parable was that you
wouldn't expect a dirty Samaritan to help someone. It was a nationalist
themed criticism of the establishment. Very punk rock. >> Less
than 1% of the federal budget wouldn't really do anything.
Wait, is a Samaritan somebody from Samarind? Is that like what
a Samaritan is >> significant to the healthare system in
America if you added it on there? Or it wouldn't boost defense
all that much if you added it there. It wouldn't boost infrastructure
all that much if you added it there. But if you send it to foreign
aid, it can save like hundreds of thousands of lives, then that
would make more sense. No, that that would be the Christian argument,
I think, if you're talking about good Samaritan. Example, if
you need to establish a military outpost, which is very important
in wars, by the way, you have these countries, good relationships
where you might be able to establish an embassy and be able to
go there. USA is not only just good practically, it's also morally
good because guess what? Children in Africa dying because of
malaria when we can just help them is bad actually. And if America,
for
>> Okay, so man, that's rough because you're kind of opening
up. Could you not make the attack
that lots of libs make on Republicans the same Samaria? Oh, Jude
and Samaria. That is way more likely. Thank you. Yes.
So, there's an attack here that you could open up that would
be very similar to what libs do on Republicans over pro-life
talking points, right? Oh, well, you care about life up until
they're born. Oh, you care about the you care about malaria injections
up until that person's eating. and then oh I guess you just starve
to death to death now buddy. Is it moral to do that kind of program
and then like let those people and then given that you have a
hard time projecting out how much more age you need to send to
make up for the increased life expectancy
like are you actually advertising what the cost of the program
is effectively?
Are you committing to costs that are way higher overall?
I was just going to watch somebody said oh loner box's comments
are crazy. I don't think they're crazy. I just think he's like
I'm more laughing at how he's like kind of >> after USA.
Do you know how many people died after USA got ended?
>> 600,000. 23 of which were children. By the way, >> the
disease programs are specifically to keep them from mutating.
It's not a selfless endeavor. It's pandemic control >> Okay,
that sounds like a better rational than what I've heard so far.
That's not the rationale that Erdite is providing.
Tagging that rationale, but if that's if that's the rationale
and that makes sense, that's a good rationale. Not very Christian
of us.
>> You support that. [laughter] >> I support American.
>> But it's kind of funny that that goes back to my whole
point. I asked you your opinion on that. I missed it. Um
I do find it interesting that a lot of the USAD stuff probably
is serving American interest then in some way or another, right?
Like even the Ukraine aid is obviously serving American interest.
It's like probably most of the things people see for aid programs
like a lot of it is just straight up serving American interest.
You have not been making that point even less. Shut up. You're
not making that point. Unless Hold on. Did you make the point
about vaccines that it's about pandemic control? You made that
point. That's a good point. Look at the logs. Nope. You're talking
about how it's good.
Africa's on the come up. You have to give it a value. You let
them live to die. That can't be an argument. Quantify the value
of foreign aid. If we could put some numbers on it, it'd be easier.
That is a thing talking about the value. Um, but you we catch
it abroad. We probably don't want to take care of it abroad,
so we don't. That's not pandemic control. That's like mutation
prevention would be about getting the number of like active and
active cases down, right? Give it fewer chances to mutate, less
chances to spread. You made one good comment, which to be fair,
out of like the hundreds of comments you made was better than
I was expecting. >> And policy is the benefit of >> Yeah.
Yeah. Support. >> Mhm. I got you. >> Let's get back.
I support America.
>> And I don't know how you're saying that's incompatible
with Christianity >> because Christians shouldn't be fundamentally
oriented by being selfish. You're saying, "Well, I might help
these poor people, but only if I know that it's going to help
me first." Very Christian, by the way. >> If I'm patriotic
and I say, "I care about Americans. I support
I actually can't believe she said that cuz that was my thing.
It's like, dude, the Ukraine war is like the definition of like
a non-Christian way of continuing something of like looking like
you're helping people and making a moral argument about it, but
actually you're not helping them at all. You're just like, "Oh,
you just want to keep giving bodies up to with Russia's economy.
Yeah, we'll give you weapons all day. Come over here. Come over.
You want to you you want a Stinger missile? You want a You want
a Javelin? You you know about Javelins? You want a Javelin? Here's
a javelin. >> Court policies that are going to >> Why
is there so much talking in the background? Do you think this
would be a like a debate where you listen to the the speakers?
What's going on? >> Help me. >> Are there like five
people in the front row and just a bunch of people yapping in
the background >> and then everybody else? >> Are
you talking to me or are you talking to them? >> I'm talking
to them. Yes. >> Why? I'm talking to you. You're >> Maybe
it's like there's another room >> If I support policies
that are going to place American interests first and help Americans
doesn't mean we can't help anyone else, but I care about Americans
more than others because I'm American. >> Allow his son
to die because it was good for him. Did Christ allow his son
to die because it was just good for him? >> No, he loved
others. And I think we should love others, too. >> Would
you say it was actually selfless? >> I'm not loving my
fellow country man if I care about someone on the other side
of the world. I can't just care about both. I feel like I can
both support welfare within my state. Of course, I can. We do
it right now. We have We only have a limited amount of resources
and >> yet America was able to both manage a welfare state
and US aid. >> So, where's your limit? Where's your limit?
How about that? Where's your limit for helping others? Do you
have one? Like when it comes to America sending our money overseas,
like do you have a limit? Like there's a certain point where
it's at a detriment to
>> right? Have to establish the detriment. I mean the amount
of money that America would have to be sending overseas that
would actually be
>> Why doesn't she just say I wouldn't all you have to
do here on airate side right is say I would never support aid
that is detrimental to America cuz that's obviously true
that's that's the whole point but she's she's arguing not what
like liberals should be arguing she's arguing like because Christians
are charitable and should be charitable that you shouldn't have
a problem with more money going over she's like arguing it in
the worst way possible to be like the foil for the other side.
>> Detrimental. One of the problems with this is again
your lack of foreign policy knowledge. For example, why is it
good for America to send weaponry to Ukraine? Do you know why?
>> I think it's good because Ukraine can be an ally. I
see Ukraine as part of
Man, I'm sorry.
Just if you think there's any reason the US supports Ukraine
that isn't just making that Russian machine burn itself to death
using Ukrainian lives to to like pay for it, it's over. >> Sort
of an American outpost right now. I support American imperialism.
So I would be okay with that. >> Right. So when you're
asking for like the sliding scale of like how much is too much?
It's like you're you're fundamentally not even understanding
the way that foreign policy exchange happens which is still devoid
from the Christian argument for example which would say as a
good Samaritan what did he do he pulled over he gave him a >> the
America first movement is not broadly about imperialism or hasn't
been seems like Fentes is shifting that up a little bit I don't
know I didn't think it was actually like for a long time it was
principally not about imperialism
he's just only recently started saying other [__]
>> has wine and oil and he paid for everything and Christ
laed that individual Yeah, I think we should do that. If you
poor children in in Africa getting [laughter] >> somebody
on the street who needs something, help them out. That's good
on an individual level, but it doesn't work with politics. Our
nation's policies have to prioritize. It's like our nation has
to help us out. >> So, first of all, that's still just
bad foreign policy. There's a reason why all Western democracies
have created this like exchange rate. >> You're for some
reason thinking I don't support backing Ukraine when I have said
multiple times that you support us aid. I'm saf what? >> US
aid. I've asked you a million times. Do you support US aid? >> Probably
not. Like I don't know what
and why.
>> Why you got such a strong opinion? I feel like US aid
was like the big example of American foreign aid unless she's
talking about military, but military is a
>> Wait, I don't think it would be. Would
I don't think is most of that a part of US aid. Is that actually
true?
Because I thought
I thought like basically
almost all of the is it is it me or is it almost all of the my
misunderstanding or is almost all of the aid US the US gives
to most of the countries around the US canal likely under the
oposes of keeping that canal like on with like hold on uh US
aid 2024 by country. US foreign assistance by country. I thought
USA ID was like a grab bag. No, give me the breakdown. entry.
Wait, what? Can you just
Yeah, dashboard or something? Give me a dashboard. What does
a dashboard say? 82 billion in obligations. So, that's a lot
of aid that is not USA ID,
A lot of that going to Africa.
I was more interested with where it was going in the Middle East.
Jeez, a lot of this stuff, huh? Yeah, I realize US aid is aid,
but foreign aid is not all US ID. I don't believe so. Right.
to spread democracy, also to fight Chinese influence, maybe.
Whatever. I'll just continue on with this for a little bit. >> A
lot more obviously selfishly driven than than uh than USAD.
Like you can argue like maybe maybe if America stopped Well,
they have stopped it really. Maybe [snorts] if they stopped the
food kitchens in Sudan, maybe uh wouldn't actually affect America
at all. Maybe you could just take that like 2% of the federal
budget and put it towards like healthare and maybe a few more
people get vaccinated if they want it. It's America. But you
would still probably argue that
a dollar goes a much longer way in Sudan than it does in the
United States, especially given the situation. So >> are
these people effective altruists? These are these guys all EA
What's going on here? What's what's the deal? We're effective
altruists. You can make the argument that America might have
like like American people might get a very marginal benefit if
they just allowed the people depend on US aid to die. But the
military aid is a lot more like that's a lot more to do with
very direct uh influence and soft power and much more concrete
ramifications for America especially to do with the way it affects
trade and stability.
Technically, [clears throat]
couldn't you use this argument to double USA ID pretty easily?
Like if this were if this were a good argument, you what is the
argument against doubling USA ID >> and everything else?
So I don't really know why she wouldn't know anything about USA
ID. It's good PR. Yeah, like there are selfish reasons for it.
Um
but again like the point in USA ID and foreign a necessarily
because you want to do good PR. If you did obviously you could
sp why not spend more? Why not make it like 5% of the federal
budget, right? Like the reason it is so low is it's because it's
not just like the PR you get for it isn't that big and because
you make such a massive difference with such a small amount of
money uh proportionately and also because but the better argument
for it if especially if you're talking to a Christian is that
like it's good to help people when you can. It doesn't cost you
that much.
I don't know. >> Only reason you
>> I think at the scales we're talking about you make a
lot of real differences in Americans lives. That's probably why
it's like you could make a lot more difference in a lot more
Africans's lives, but at the scale that US aid goes out at, you
can make real tangible improvements in Americans lives
and with how people are struggling right now, it's really difficult
to justify making even even if you were able to spend 10 to one,
right? If you're able to spend 10 to one on
like you get 10 times the improvement in Africa over what it
is in America, people are still going to say no because they're
struggling right now. So while while this is true and yes, you
can do a lot of charity and it's more effective over there, I
don't I don't know why you expect people to care. >> You
support Ukraine is because it benefits us. >> US aid if
it benefits America in some >> Yeah. This is like the uncristian
piece, right? Like if you're just a secularist who's like, honestly,
I'm selfish. As long as it benefits me, then I'm happy. That
would be fine. Wait a second. American fine. No, I'm Canadian.
>> fun fact. I believe this person is also >> Okay.
So that's why I don't care about putting America first. You're
Canadian. >> You don't even understand your own foreign
policy. That's not a dunk like you think it is. I can assure
you, my friends, if a Canadian if a Canadian understands your
politics better than you do, that's a dunk.
>> I support you going back to Canada and being Canada
first over there and I'm going to be America first here. >> I'm
a legal immigrant of America. Is that a problem for you? >> Don't
clap, please. >> I I don't know. I think it's fine. I I
support a morator.
>> Like our parents like if we did that like it's disrespectful.
Like >> cuz if I were to immigrate to another country,
I would try to fit in. I would try to assimilate. >> Yeah.
Exactly. >> To that culture, right? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. I think they were
>> Dude, they just ran back Lauren Southern like one to
one. Rebel news segment
fighting race fighting the race war in Canada then moving to
America. >> Not promised anything. So I think the protest
is
they just they just ran it back one to
That's so lazy. What are these writers doing, man?
That's insanely lazy. I thought this was like maybe her slimiest
moment in this debate is to pull out the Canadian card when she
herself is Canadian. What the [__] is that about,
man? >> I am right now, so >> Well, I'm white, so
that's a good one,
>> I'll I'll let you stay. It's okay.
>> Relevant unexpected crossover episode. Wow. Wait, that's
like right now.
Damn.
Guessing that's also in Arizona. It's good to get out of Canada
and for a minute and visit some old friends and colleagues. My
US passport flag was removed after nearly 5 years. But as of
me rejecting CESUS, I now have a flag upon entry to Canada. So
the results in me being detained each time I come home.
Worth it.
Michaela, take care of Jordan. Okay. Okay. Actual justice warrior.
Wow. What a multithnic, multi-racial, multi-gendered racist coalition.
Got to love it. Only in America, guys. >> Well, are you
h >> choice? What?
Imagine inviting someone to come and have a nice friendly chat
at a bar and then ambushing them and attacking them like Hennessy
is right now. True. So [snorts] univil, so uncristian, poor
>> Are you okay with me being an immigrant in your country?
>> Um, I just said I'll let you say sure. >> I I
don't Okay, I don't even know what Canada. That's fine, I guess.
Okay. So if we want to go back for example, US generosity is
the leading form of global health and humanitarian relief. US
Aid saves lives by preventing HIV, preventing disrupting labor
issues on the other side.
Why why as a nation who was born on a you would probably argue
Christian values? Why would a nation develop for centuries to
have a policy of understanding and helping others not just within
our borders but outside of it? And now you as a great smart Christian
nationalist comes along and says actually it's more Christian
to only care about Americans because I think somewhere in the
Bible so God says God loved everyone but actually he only liked
Americans, right? I think it's probably
this is like the laziest version of the argument. It's just like
like Sarah clearly doesn't know what she thinks. She clearly
like I thought she was smart off the bat. She was calling Aerodite
out in the right right pieces but then she fell apart as soon
as it got to anything concrete. Very
But like the the idea that you're just like, "Well, actually,
you're Christian, so you have to be okay with us giving this
money away."
That's so dumb. It's just so lazy. >> Galatians 3:28. Let's
see. There is no
>> There is a There is both Greek and non-Greek, nor
branded or theology or female for one of you all in one place.
>> Do you have you heard of the concept of ordered love?
>> Yeah, of course. >> So, do you agree with it?
>> Uh, it it depends. What does this even mean? In what
context? >> Um, in the context, >> Wow, how smug.
What is that delivery?
In what context? Damn, so rude.
>> Like I mentioned before, caring for your family before
other people. >> This poor young blonde woman. >> Uh,
so again, depends on what we mean. Like if I say neglect your
family, well, why are you laughing? Of course, right? If you
say, should you neglect your family? No,
>> obviously not. But the issue is that >> what if
you're neglecting your family to help other >> Did she
say yes of course and then say what does that mean? Well, she
said in what context like why are you how are you using it?
I think both sides have like a reasonable argument here but the
debate ended up just being garbage that didn't actually approach
the issue in any meaningful way. >> Other people is that
justified in your
>> I was just watching to see if Voter Box would say anything
here.
>> Okay. So >> I just said neglect is bad. But the
issue is you're acting the America first paradigm acts like this
is a zero sum game, right? The idea that you have to like put
America first and foremost while as you said is maybe a good
idea if all you care about is being greedy and concerned with
your own self. But again, you're a Christian. Christians should
not be fundamentally focused on only helping others because it
benefits them. Which is what you said. You said I'll help them
but only if it benefits me. There's not a single thing that's
Christian about that. Right? Christianity is fundamentally about
generosity to others. It's about looking at people and seeing
them with love. It's about looking past the borders and saying
you are loved because God made you, not because you're American,
not because you're white. >> Again, it's like
>> Thanks for the $5 bulb. Spider isn't here, so I'll ask
you a spiderlike question. Do you uh think the Austrian painter
guy was anti-semitic? Uh maybe a little lowkey type. Yeah, good
one, >> Christian. And what you're do, >> dude. Spider's
just catching the most insane shots from randos.
Dude, that was up. That was a donation. He can't even defend
himself. >> You can have these PR.
>> Uh, like I don't know. Uh, yeah.
bad or some like bad or some >> But you don't for a second.
>> I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not that type. I'm I'm not
a not [__] >> Have to pretend that it's Christian.
>> I I think
>> Bro, why don't >> it's just like odd that you
>> I I don't even know why I went to this. Honestly, I
really don't care. I was just I thought it I started watching
and then I was like, "Oh, Lerbox not reacting." And then I kept
watching and Lerbox is like barely talking.
I don't Man, I think I think it's good to like react like a lot
if you can. I think there are times where I push it too far.
I pause too often. I say the same things like I probably spend
a little too much time talking, but I don't understand why you
wouldn't like risk I don't understand why you wouldn't risk
being on that side of it versus being on the side where you like
don't comment. Feels like quite bad. I I don't know. I feel quite
bad when I do that, but whatever. Whatever.
How long we been streaming for?
Five and a half hours. Damn. Want to get back in Desty's good
graces. I don't see why you would say that. I don't think that.
I don't know why you would think that to be honest with you,
but okay man.
eventually we'll test the theory. Eventually I do believe that
you guys could push him to like start hanging out with Destiny
again if every single time he continues to like basically say
this guy's a degenerate I want nothing to do with. You keep like
holding him to the opinion that he is like wants to be friends
with Destiny, wants to get back to hanging out with Destiny.
I do think people could eventually push him to the point where
he go like, "Well, uh, I guess I just have to pick that side
because I I probably need to be on a side." I think you could
do that. I think that could happen eventually.
That would be his faults.
Okay. Yeah. You Nobody would bear any responsibility there. Yep.
Cuz everybody needs to be able to stand up against all public
pressure forever, always, no matter what. Did I say he would
have zero blame? I don't think so.
You're too hearty for that to work on you. Um, I think I'm too
hardy for it to work on me now.
Also, nobody argues I'm on Destiny's side. But let's say like
eventually if like Hassan reached out to me, wanted to collab.
I don't really agree with Hassan's politics, right? This wouldn't
happen. But let's just say for the sake of argument. Um,
I'm not going to say that I wouldn't think about it purely on
the I it would be nice to like have an ingroup that I could actually
hang out with and be cool
I don't think that's crazy to think that. I I disagree with that
guy's like politics and [__] too. By the way, it's
like a madeup example that wouldn't happen, but like it wouldn't
be in line with like a lot of the principles I've stated before
where I do think he's like kind of a grifter. I just think he's
like funny now more than I think he's a grifter. But um just
for the sake of the hypothetical, I'm saying like you sometimes
it's just nice to not have every single community hate you.
You know what I'm saying? is nice. Cuz realistically, I'm telling
you, if you're just honest with people most of the time,
you won't have anywhere to go on the internet. The perfectly
honest person is ostracized from the internet.
That's not me, by the way. I'm not ostracized from the internet.
But I think if you had somebody who's like perfectly honest and
reading things correctly and telling people like where they're
failing all the time, I think that person would be totally like
rejected by a ton of communities and and not have a place. It's
just about whether you want to accept that or not. Just go pro
Nick. Oh, could do that one too. Yeah, maybe that's a better
one. That's probably a better one, Mr. Girl. Um, a little bit.
Little bit. I do I do broadly think that though, that like most
of your connections are people you're like slightly less critical
of. And if you're perfectly critical of your connections at all
times, usually those connections don't last. At least in this
space where it's like about who's right and who's wrong. Hold
on, let me check out this tweet really quickly. There's some
one of from one of those unredacted emails. Assistant US attorney
writes in 2020, Donald Trump traveled on Epstein's jet more many
more times than previously has been reported, including during
the period we would expect to charge in a Maxwell case. Didn't
want any of this to be a surprise down the road. For your situational
awareness, wanted to let you know that the flight records we
received yesterday reflect that Donald Trump traveled on Epste's
private jet many more times than we than previously has been
reported or that we were aware, including during the period where
we expect to charge in a Maxwell case. In particular, he is listed
as a passenger on at least eight flights between 93 and 96, including
at least four flights on which Maxwell was also present. He is
listed as having traveled with, among others and at various times,
Mara Maples, his daughter Tiffany, and his son Eric. On one flight
in 1993, he and Epstein are the only two listed passengers. On
another, the only three passengers are Epste and then 20-year-old
blank.
On two other flights, two of the passengers respectively were
women who would be possible witnesses in a Maxwell case. We've
just finished reviewing the rec full records. More than 100 pages
of very small script and didn't want any of this to be a surprise
down the road
Oh no, not a a USA. See the statement Bill Clinton made. Um yeah,
I saw it. Manic Inc. Yep. We covered it. It was pretty cool.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Okay. I think um
with that this was just going to be a short stream, so I don't
have like a whole bunch else. a whole bunch of other stuff I
want to do really.
Um, I think I'm gonna be up for a while. There's a chance if
I see some stuff I want to cover, maybe I hang out later. Maybe
I like stream later. Maybe this morning or something. We'll see.
I got to go do some stuff. I got to go pack my bags to go home
for Christmas.
um, I'll do that and then I'll see what's up after that. Civ.
I might play some Civ. We'll see. But I got to go pack and stuff
first. All right. So, if I don't talk to you guys, I think I
will. I think I'll probably stream tomorrow. Maybe I'll stream
Christmas Eve. I don't know about Christmas Day. I'll have to
take my laptop with me and stream from my laptop. And I haven't
done that in a while. So, I'll have to update OBS. Maybe that's
what I'll do tonight. Maybe at some point later I'll go live
and just try to get my laptop working for streaming.
We'll get like OBS reinstalled. Try to get like some of the graphics
over there that I have on this computer and Oh, part two of Honey.
Yeah, we can do that as well. Yeah, it was a late start tonight
and I'm like on a weird sleep schedule. So,
yeah, we'll see. We'll see what we're going to do. Had fun just
showing up, hanging out, chatting it up for a little bit. Okay.
All right. Have a good night, guys. Be back tomorrow, the next
day. Not totally sure yet, but we will be back. Thank you so
much for the support. Appreciate you guys. Talk to you later.